it's not it what it's about like there's
a certain standard in society for women
of how we should be and we're kind of
like taught that not saying it's verbal
right that's pushed on us from
it's okay
it's a form of primary like i have a
teammate that i played volleyball with
her mother would not let her leave the
house without her nails done her hair
done and outfit and now i [ __ ] with
her i would be inside every day
but it's because she said no man is
going to want you
because you don't look the part
and but that's what it is but if that's
if that's the if that's the case why are
statistically the majority of women
overweight
like if that's the case if we were
forced to look a certain way right
that's the standard right that's the
like standard then like i don't and men
don't accept that there's a lot of
things that go into
being overweight and if we go back to
what we talked about first about toxic
relationship and just like just stuff
that we go through emotionally
i think that
women i'm not saying that men don't go
through things emotionally but i feel
like women go through more emotionally
and have things right we're more more
emotional yeah yeah and from that the
the easiest thing to resort to is eating
and
just being
um well they changed our food to comfort
from the 50s yeah and so i think that
that may be the one the main thing is
just like it's just comfort finding
comfort and food food's always going to
comfort you no matter what
food and
i think that that is one thing not
canceling out like men don't go through
nothing and we all yeah yeah right but
it's just like that's one thing from
just what i've seen and what i've just
like so you think the majority of like
women being overweight is from emotional
like trauma [ __ ]
like let me look can i just say yeah
yeah like growing up i was a stick like
i was stick then i was underweight i got
put on medication to gain weight because
i was unhealthily underweight right
and so i and when i was skinny it was
like all i wanted to do was have curves
like all i wanted was to have an ass
like that's all i could think about i
gained weight and then it's like the the
whole it's like the opposite right and
it's like i always felt like i was
trying to fit into a standard and it was
like never fit and i could never just be
because but it's also that's personal
on me because it's like well it's
interesting because i would look at you
like as the like you you're you're
stunning to be honest
like like that's what i'm saying but
it's interesting because like you you
i feel like you have to know you're
hotter than like most girls
are you respectful as also being six
three right like growing up i was
[ __ ] bullied because i hit six three
when i was thirteen
[Applause]
[Music]
it's funny when you say like lebron
james because like when i was in middle
school like people would be like oh kobe
bryant lebron james stop watching all
right we say that in the tall girl movie
sasquatch and it's like that has an
effect on you and like people would
always make comments to me like i was
like 120 pounds and i was six three like
i was a [ __ ]
twins
like
it was gross like i looked like a
skeleton right and then it's like all i
wanted was this one it was the curves
yes
but you showed me pictures you were
curvy yeah up to a point yeah like i
gained a lot of muscle right but then i
got on medication right gained a lot of
weight and then i was like
do you just want to be well do you do
you feel like that's society or that's
like an internal it's internal yeah
right because society is either like
you're either a good curvy or you're
there's nothing
but it's interesting i'm skinny and
there's bad stuff but it's interesting
because i like to me it's all like like
i think women are meaner to women than
men are to be honest like girls
like girls
but also the part where women are more
critical comes from their insecurities
oh yeah projection rejection
women are very general that doesn't i
know but it doesn't make it okay
absolutely not no yeah
what you meant by that like women are
meaner to women like most guys aren't
you know like men swipe on right on like
fifty percent of women like most men
aren't that rhythm most most no one's
saying most men aren't that picky like
they're also
they're they're attracted to the
well most men are attracted to like like
a lot of women like it's the if you're
getting rejected by guys they're in a
very small percentage of men like 10 to
15 percent of men even like they say um
20 of men have access to 80 of the women
so the reason that we hate men is
because we're all effing the same ones
yeah
like if you want a guy that's six foot
in the top 15 percent of math literally
yeah yeah income on that yeah yeah and
so i'm saying the majority of men aren't
picky and so so women because we're
competing for those men
like they they tear at each other
each other because like from example
like
okay personally yeah never say there's
not a man that i've wanted that i
haven't got personally yeah let them
know
there's been men that i've rejected that
have been like well i don't want your
fat ass anyways oh yeah oh yeah i'm
saying so it's like but like that [ __ ]
like sticks with you like you know yeah
it's like but you wanted me but now
you're calling me this why are you
feeling so hard for the cookies as soon
as i rejected this you suck yeah i try
to try to make it one at a time just so
like the i've just had comments that
they can't hear because there's too many
people talking
yeah yeah i get what you're saying okay
but like you know like that [ __ ] like
sticks with a person right like like i
remember there was one time i was at cal
berkeley and this guy was hollering at
me
and i was like please [ __ ] off like he
was such a little frat boy he's like
well i don't want your fat ass anyways
this was four years ago i was skinnier
than i was like 15 pounds lighter than
like i you know what i'm saying yeah
but like that [ __ ] like sticks with a
person like well he thought i was fat
like so it's like well the girls do like
i don't know girls kind of like are
worse almost behind each other's backs
well that's true it's just not to our
face we're more we're more behind the
back that part is fun yeah even in front
of their face girls are very spicy but
it's it's more sub like shady you know
men
men can't even see the looks that girls
give us at the bar and you know exactly
what looks like the the the shade men
can't see it because um there's a
biological reasoning behind it but
basically like because women were like
gatherers and like we were more with the
kids biologically we pick up on other
people's emotions better so it's
i don't know but i do have a yeah go
ahead go ahead a question what
and this might just be like a preference
or whatever but what is the cutoff
between because nowadays being big is
is not frowned upon at all it's
not worship but it's glorified but when
does it come a point where it's like
you're thick and then you're too big
like
i think it's your body shape to be
honest because you said the statistic is
a lot of women i want to say well the
average woman is a hundred and
it's five five 155 pounds which is like
20 pounds overweight something like that
yeah over average
no no i know i know i know yeah yeah but
like the average woman i i i don't know
the exact statistic off the top of my
head but she is overweight yeah yeah
like if you went to a doctor like he
would say yeah i mean
people can say whatever they want like
i'm a curvy like curvier girl like but
women like i know personally like i gain
a lot of weight in my hips like like
some girls carry it better than others i
know like there's a like for
like
like genetically women carry more body
fat than men yes
i tend to get gain weight in my hips and
like my birthing area right like that's
where i carry my weight
so that's all like it's they're like you
know what i'm you get what i'm saying so
it's like there's like
part yes like but it's all up to
preference like what are you into right
you know right so it's like what really
it like now
well but they're talking like
stick that i think kirby ways big ass
well i think the problem is when we look
at the guys that have all the options to
pick from they all seem to pick the
models
so that says something
and the guys and the guys and the guys
name one billionaire that's not married
to a model or even they're married for
like six seven years and then they get a
divorce and is that what your goal is
not all bill gates jeff bezos both of
their wives were married 20 plus years
they did get a divorce i'm sorry
bill gates wife is not that pretty and
same she wasn't she was with
well yeah because but that's that's
because they got them young men valley
white and white men tend to like thinner
women well they they got them young
before they were even rich